der mensch vor rund vier millionen
jahren erhob sich die gattung homo auf
ihre hinterbeine und dominierte da durch
die savanne jahrmillionen später vor
rund 10.000 jahren begannen die menschen
schuhe oder genauer aus pflanzen
geflochtene sandale zu tragen doch erst
heute
2022 findet die fortbewegung des
menschen ihre vollendung ich will
motorisierte schuhe bauen mit dem man
erst ganz normal gehen kann und dann
zack da ist man einfach mit vollgas im
stehen davon also genau wie in e roller
nur halt ohne roller und erwin e bike
aber halt ohne bike
dieses video wird unterstützt von 1&1 da
die bestellung von motoren gut mal ein
bis zwei wochen dauern kann ist der
motor das erste um das ich mich kümmern
muss leider kann man hier nicht einfach
irgendein motto nehmen und leider konnte
ich auf ebay kein elektromotor für
schuhe finden komisch der motor den ich
für mein selbst gebautes menschen großes
hamsterrad als generator genutzt habe
wäre zum beispiel ein gutes stück zu
schwach eine lichtmaschine von einem
auto hätte vielleicht genug power
allerdings ist die viel zu groß und
diese mini motoren hier die würden sogar
superleicht in der schuhsohle passen
sind aber natürlich komplett machtlos
also ich hab nichts dazwischen gefunden
aber wie viel power braucht er wollte
eigentlich um mich überhaupt schieben zu
können ich habe hier ein zweites gerät
also eigentlich gerne fisch oder koffer
waage und wenn ich mich jetzt damit aus
dem stand zu
lesen hier sechs kilo die nötig sind um
mich zu bewegen oder x 9,81 59 minuten
wenn man die masse in kraft um rechnet
was sie bestimmt schon mal im
physikunterricht gehört habt wird ein
bisschen matte und ein paar formeln aus
dem internet habe ich dann also
errechnet dass ich logischerweise zwei
motoren brauche mit 400 umdrehungen pro
minute und jeweils 40 wartete mit wir
meine gewünschte höchstgeschwindigkeit
bekommen das beste was ich finden konnte
war allerdings ein komplett übertrieben
der motor der eigentlich für ein e-bike
oder eine cola gedacht ist das teil hat
alleine einfach 100 watt und davon habe
ich einen jetzt 2 1 für jeden fuß ist
klar oder das sind natürlich nicht die
einzigen teile die ich für dieses
projekt braucht hat mir auch ein
komplett übertriebenen akku gestellt
jesus ja das nie baku der 80 kilometer
reichweite hat so und das muss man jetzt
irgendwie an die schule kriegen die ich
bestellt habe und ich gehen ein bisschen
saft auf motor dieses kreis alter und
das soll jetzt irgendwie diese schuhe
hier motorisieren da sehen wir die sagen
wir fangen einfach mal an ihnen erklären
einfach
[Musik]
das hat sie jetzt gerade gepasst habe
ist eine kardanwelle die kennt ihr
vielleicht aus dem auto das gerade daran
ist dass ich jetzt kannst du mit
dieselmotor anbieten kann so und der
motor dreht halten diese stange hier
immer noch das heißt man kann die achse
einfach wiegen die sonst was jetzt kann
man hier quasi über so eine umlenkung
einfach diese drehbewegungen von hinten
vom motor auf den reifen hier übertragen
und damit sollte der spaß kommt an den
rhein kann also ich will sich an mein
bein machen weil ich habe angst dass man
beinahe preisbedingt die man das einmal
hier fest oder mit dem zweiten winkel
mache ich das kino fest dass der motor
also ich nehme das sogar auf youtube
meine pläne die kardanwelle zu verwenden
habe ich mittlerweile über bord geworfen
und möchte statt einer biegsamen achse
lieber eine kette verwenden die über
diesen zahlen kannst die kraft vom motor
an die räder überträgt aber eins nach
dem anderen zuerst kümmere ich mich um
das wichtigste was rat das rad selbst
besteht aus einem skateboard rat dass
ich einfach mit einer säge in der mitte
durchtrennt fehlt nur noch eine
halterung für die achse dafür künftig
mit riesen metall wählt ihn herum und
mache einige markierungen und bohrungen
das ding hier ist übrigens ein kölner
mit dem man eine kleine delle ins metall
macht an die stelle wo dann später der
bürger drauf kommt damit dieser seinen
weg leichter ins metall findet und nicht
wegrutscht
[Musik]
und jetzt weg geflext roman
jugendsprache hat das handwerk grünen
jetzt jetzt wird die winkelschleifer
[Musik]
eine sache die mir ein bisschen sorgen
macht ist ob ich jetzt darauf bei uns
sehen kann oder nicht wirklich das jetzt
gemacht hat spricht gebe ich dann immer
nach vorne oder und das wird jetzt schon
mal gut an kann ich nicht so ein
bisschen platzieren und nach hinten
gehen und es geht ich habe keine ahnung
wie das dann später funktionieren soll
wenn dann noch motor drin anschiebt weil
dass man sie nur noch mag ja sein aber
es geht ja jetzt nachdem ich das erste
mal ja schon fertig habe ist das zweite
dran man nehme eine achse ein flansch
lager beilag scheibe und ein halbiertes
skateboarder war dann noch einen tanz
für die kette auf dessen ende ich das
rad presse damit es hält anschließend
kommt das zweite rad und dann wieder
alles in die presse jetzt wo das
geschafft ist staubig beide achsen an
zwei winkelt die ich dann wiederum an
einen großen haupt linke schraube der
später an meine verse kommt dann wird
der motor in seinen eigenen winkel
geschoben und wird damit ebenfalls an
den haupt winkel geschraubt wodurch wir
nun auch die richtige länge der kette
bestimmen können
das funktioniert so weit schon ganz gut
allerdings sieht man jetzt wenn man hier
ein bisschen genauer hinschaut dass
sobald man sich zurücklehnt dass man
dann halt eben auf diese dinge auf kommt
das habe ich mir jetzt mal markiert wie
man hier gut sehen kann und diese
markierungen fleck sich jetzt ab und
dann soll man idealerweise hinterher
sich gut zu gelingen kann
[Musik]
wenn man sich damit jetzt nach hinten
lehnt ja dann geht man nicht an sondern
man kann sie so weit hinten liegen wie
man möchte ist euch in den letzten 30
sekunden eigentlich irgendwas
aufgefallen nein das will nämlich alles
mit dem neuen samsung s 22 ultra
gefallen ist schon krass wie gut
handykameras mittlerweile sind oder 1&1
hat mir nämlich die drei neuen samsung
smartphones zugeschickt und ich konnte
die letzten tage schon ein bisschen aus
tasten ein mega cool trikot der serie
ist zb auto fremming eine funktion die
darauf achtet dass immer der optimalen
bildausschnitt gewählt wird selbst wenn
sich immer bewegt das samsung galaxy s2
an sich ultra gibt es in vier
verschiedenen farben fenster black white
green und bürgern die und an internen
speicher können zwischen 128 256 und 512
gewalt wählen schnappt euch jetzt
bereits ab 0 euro einmalig in der 1&1
all-net-flat über den link in der
infobox dann erhaltet ihr zusätzlich die
galaxy bansko im wert von 229 euro
kostenlos dazu und für euer altes handy
kommen noch einmal mindestens 160 euro
tausch prämie obendrauf so nicht mehr
das sagen wir bauen die beiden babys mal
hier in die schule ein dafür werde ich
jetzt quasi einmal diese regatta über
eine kette oder durch eine kette durch
wedeln ist halt direkt eine richtig gute
übertragung mich dazu bewegt dann
spricht das an den motor an und jetzt
wenn sich der motor dreht dann reden sie
dann auch die rede und damit sind
eigentlich ultra nahrung sommerergebnis
vorhanden und jetzt werde ich es hier
ebenso festschrauben doch bevor ich die
schrauben verschrauben kann muss ich
natürlich noch die passenden löcher
bohren und wie man hier sieht passt das
konstrukt dank der form des oberen
winkels perfekt zusammen die kette
verläuft als wäre der winkel dafür
geschaffen durch die einkerbung die
zusätzlich dafür sorgt dass der winkel
stabiler ist und nicht verbiegt dass die
kette die perfekte länge hat ist
übrigens kein zufall ich musste sie
selber kürzen und das ist überhaupt gar
nicht leicht so dieser mechanismus
funktioniert hat so weit kann es dass
trainer der motor dreht sich oder der
motor dreht sich und das rad dreht sich
pakistan nach oben drauf und schaut das
so funktioniert liegen ich mir erhoffe
käufers geil mehr
[Musik]
okay ich mache nicht folgen damit
falscher 80 kalwa
hieß es dass laut
[Musik]
das hat schon ab
megageil sie nur noch schauen dass das
teil hier weil die apparate funktioniert
jetzt quasi in diese schule verbaut wird
ich bin so hey ich hab sofort da
wiederum zu fahren
es ist mir aufgefallen dass ich ja
genauso wie vorhin auch schon einmal
mein fuß aufstellen kann nur dieses mal
gas geben kann jetzt kann ja mal power
geben und habt ja der los dann fest dass
ihr davon das heißt es fehlt einfach das
einzige was jetzt eigentlich noch fehlt
ist das ding in den schulen zu bauen und
natürlich noch im zweiten satz davon zu
machen schlägt sich irgendwie sonst was
so ich hatte das ganze ding noch mal
gemacht für das andere bein wenn jetzt
hier auf dich hab' halt machen
gestöpselt
bewegen sich begeistern
und ihr wisst was es heißt das heißt ich
kann jetzt einfach nicht mehr auf halde
draufstellen mal gas geben muss schauen
was passiert
[Musik]
ich verstehe echt noch nicht mehr so das
ding ich als produkt existiert weil es
funktioniert und ich glaube ich dass es
gut spaß machen wird als nächstes müssen
die schub auf sätze wie ich sie jetzt
einfach mal nur noch an die schule
montiert werden dazu sage ich die sohle
an der ferse ab mit einer säge die ja
eigentlich für holz gedacht ist schon
ziemlich lustig wie simpel so eine marke
schuhsohle aufgebaut ist danach entferne
ich die einlage und lege eine
metallplatte in den schuh die ich dann
durch löcher die teilweise erst noch
gebohrt werden müssen mit unserem shop
aufsatz für schraube und zwar wirklich
fest da ich keine lust haben später bei
vollgas umzuknicken anschließend kommen
die einlagen wieder hinein und fertig
ist unser erster motor show also das
sind definitiv sehr sehr einzigartige
schuhe die ich mir jetzt sorgen gehabt
also der schule schon recht schwer aber
man kann damit gehen es fühlt sich an
als würde ein bisschen mit high heels
rumlaufen tatsächlich wenn jetzt nicht
zurücklehnen dann bin ich auf dem fuß
das klappt eigentlich auch ganz gut ich
mal wissen was risikoreiches probieren
das hier ist ein geschwindigkeitsregler
den ich mir für 20 euro im internet
bestellt habe damit die motoren sobald
ich sie an den akku schließe nicht
einfach direkt immer vollgas geben denen
muss ich jetzt verbauen und das geht
überraschende weise super easy einfach
stromquelle auf die eine seite und den
motor auf die andere und jetzt kann ich
hier mit diesem regler genau einstellen
wie viel prozent schob die motoren geben
sollen
okay die schuhe sind so als fertig und
schreien nur so nach einem test so schön
fest für einen guten halt da mache ich
mal hier den akku an das kommt in den
rucksack das ist richtig geil ich finds
megane eis einfach jetzt motor schuld zu
haben glaube ich habe ich mal wieder
fest also die balance ist schon super
tricky
praxis also man braucht richtig gute
körperspannung
die uefa
[Musik]
nur
hilfe alter ruhig glauben sie mir
nochmals überlegen weil die balance zu
halten damit das ist super schwierig
auch wenn theoretisch natürlich genug
power hätte mich zu transportieren
ansehen welche unnormal power
mein gott ich kann's kaká so richter und
sweet spot gefunden
[Musik]
also man stellt sich so hin gibt es ein
gericht auf einen bein langsam an gas zu
geben und dann lädt man sich plötzlich
hinten auf beide beine dann fährt man
es macht extrem bob und skeleton lernen
kann aber leider habe ich einfach nicht
genug platz deswegen müssen wir
eigentlich mal eine tour draußen machen
davor gibt es aber noch mal keinen
boxenstopp ich ziehe noch mal alle
lockeren teile fest und optimiere auch
die eine oder andere sache bevor mir
dann auffällt dass ich die schule am
besten noch mal mit den welt
schlechtesten schweißnähten bestücken
damit sie bombenfest sind und ich nicht
durch abbrechende teile stürze
sicherheit gehe auf jeden fall vorbei so
eine konstruktion gut und hat jetzt die
schuhe für ein bekenntnis dass ich die
leute denken müssen da staunt sogar dazu
der junge
ich will mir genauso ein gutes stück
fahren können
[Musik]
oder sie die schule habe
das hätte sonst richtig gut gefahren
hier ist
nun links hier ausgefeilten schon aber
da ich es geschafft hat es ist auch egal
sie sind das aber für zehn sekunden
gleich ein vogel auf dem fahrradweg mit
meinen strom gefahren ist und ich würde
sagen ich gebe mich anzutreten schade
weil der krisenschock gehabt erst einmal
darum zu wissen ich meine hätten damit
ich hätte hier 80 kilometer reichweite
und ich hatte einmal komplett quer durch
sonst was weg lösen können ich würde das
zeug auf jeden fall mal überarbeiten
weil es funktioniert und es macht uwe
bock abonniert dafür gern mein zweiter
von video beschreibung verlinkt auch in
der video beschreibung könnt ihr euch
jetzt das neue samsung galaxy s 22 0
traf in der 10 1 all net flat holen und
damit verabschiede ich mich von dem
video ja und ich muss jetzt nach hause
gehen
[Musik]